so imagine you're in business with
somebody who's very talented but they
don't have the right character you don't
trust them
they have the right contacts they're not
workers they have the right skills
but they haven't bought into you they're
not team players they're good team
players they're selfish
how do you prioritize what's the right
ranking for you to say
i'm going to be in business with this
person along tomorrow now i had a friend
of mine today
yesterday came up to me and he's about
to finish up
a business relationship with him they
had an investor relationship together
but he had a fallen out he says i can't
do business with this person i said why
after a series of questions i said let
me tell you how i process who i do
business with
and who i don't long term and this is my
formula i've presented it to him he says
oh my gosh this is so much clearer
i said i'm going to have to make this
into a how-to so here you are watching
us
[Music]
here's how these things work this thing
works i got different
categories here when it comes down to
people i do business with
one is character the other one is trust
the other one is work ethic
we have vision somebody that's bought in
then you have
competency skill set then you have
rolodex
and contact so now you kind of have an
idea what we're looking at now on this
side to the left i've ranked them
from zero to ten right so you can rank
on different categories then i'll
explain to you trust in a way that
will make a lot of sense to you so let's
look at the first one character
is this person someone to do business
with lowest level anything less than
four they lie they cheat they steal at
all costs they'll do business
at all costs it doesn't matter what it
is even if it ruins you hurts your
business okay
next one is four to seven they're
selfish but honest listen i don't mind
doing business with selfish people who
are honest
meaning hey i want to do this and i want
to make money and no no and they'll try
to over negotiate for themselves
i'm okay with that because there's still
an element of honesty
but they're selfish and then the last
one is what anything above eight nine
ten
fair reasonable honest and a team player
meaning
character solid i can do business with
this guy because he or she is fair
they're reasonable we can have dialogue
together they're honest and they're a
team player let's go make this happen
together phenomenal obviously you want
the score to be what
higher next one trust stranger
acquaintance friend running mate you
could put a score to yourself and say
like if you're thinking about a guy
let's just say
john you know what john to me is a seven
and a half when it comes down to what
character
john to me and trust he's probably more
of a five he could be a two
but he could be nine he could be an
eight i totally trust this guy
did he got work ethic you have the 459
club what is that they can't wait till
they boom they're out here at 459 right
so they're not workers which means
you may trust them they may have a great
character
phenomenal human being but has no desire
to work that hard they're very much
about i just want to do enough and i'm
out
then they could be the next one sprints
of hard work they'll work hard for 30
days
and then they disappear for 60 days
they'll go for 90 days you won't see
them for six months
so you know where to put them here then
you have the last one which is what
obsessive
driven committed non-stop right so
imagine if you have somebody today
strong character fair reasonable honest
team player good running mate you trust
them
their workers obsessive-driven non-stop
we have something very special going on
here right
but that's not enough next one is vision
and bought in
so you'll sit down you're talking to
john let's just say you'll say you know
what
he's a hater he hasn't bought and he's a
total hit anything i say
but you don't realize this is not gonna
work right or he's a doubter you know
what i don't know if it's gonna work but
maybe i don't know
or it's like true believer do it let's
go make it happen i'm all in
this is going to take place right so you
got bought in hater
doubter true believer or vision small
thinking
average thinker big thinker now
obviously if you got somebody that's
here at the top all four
you got a pretty good thing going with
this relationship then we got the next
one competency
and this is where sometimes you have a
challenge because at the competency
level
there could be an amateur there could be
experience they could be expert if you
have
all of these four things but they're
amateurs
they're just somebody that's good to
have on the team but they're not yet
somebody that's gonna increase the value
of the company but you don't have to go
to sleep at night thinking about they're
gonna hurt you or harm you
now if you got somebody whose skill set
is an expert
but all of this is low you go to sleep
every night worried about what this
person is going to do to you to harm you
because you can't
trust them and you know they're not in
it with you right okay then last but not
least is rolodex contacts
is it limited is it broad is it
specialized is it local
is it national is it global is it people
who have
wealth influence massive context then
it's up here right so now
you look at this here you got a value
for yourself
who is it that i want to be in business
with so let's talk about somebody here
now you may say
you're in business with somebody he's
your boss okay
so when you think about here skill set
he's a high
he's a big thinker he's obsessive okay
and he's a acquaintance of yours you've
known him for a while
but you don't trust them at all right
that's a challenge right there what are
you going to do with this person long
term
if you know that's a boss that you
report to now you may say this person
i'm working with
has all these things expertise is low
but their contact is high man this guy's
got a lot of good contact his last name
is dot dot dot right
so he was he is willing to take
advantage of his contacts and ex
open it up so we can go do big things
raise money whatever it may be
this leads me to this which is a big one
remember how we talk about trust here on
the yellow watch the trust here
what do you do if the problem with this
the trust is someone you report to
it's your superior or someone that's
your colleague and a direct report
why does this matter so much patrick
here's why
if the person you don't trust is your
superior
you can't do nothing about this this
ain't changing
you cannot change the human being and
you have no control over it
if that's the above you now if the
person you're doing business with
and you're like man this co-worker of
mine i tell he's annoying i don't i
don't
trust this guy but he doesn't have
influence over you because you're a
colleague right you don't report to him
he doesn't report to you
you just know you're in business with
this if he has a chance to backstab you
to get a position
you know he's going to do it right and
every company there's these types of
dynamics they have to deal with but the
last one is he reports to you
now he may report to you he may be
skilled at what he's doing
he may be an average thinker he may be
a not even a worker let's just say he's
here he goes on sprints
he may be an acquaintance at this point
with you and you don't trust him at all
here
but because he reports to you you still
have some controls together
this way when you're doing business and
if you take this whole
chart that i give you i'm going to give
you a pdf here in a minute if you take
this whole chart that i just gave you
you put it together and you put
everybody that you're doing business
with run them through it give them a
score
so put next to it john and say john
is a seven a five a four
a nine a seven a six you get what i'm
saying
and then come up with the score the
higher the score the score ought to be a
total of 60 points
the closer to 60 somebody good you're
dealing with
above 50 you're in a good situation so
when you're doing this
also do it in superior here's the people
i report to
go through the score here's my
colleagues i work with
go through their score here's the people
that report to me go through their score
when you look at your supervisors you
may need to kind of be thinking about
where you are right if the scores aren't
too high for score
but if the score is a high score like
this is phenomenal if you go through
your
colleagues you're working with then
associate yourself with the people that
are above 50 score
okay people that want to do something
big if the people that are direct report
to you
and you put the score work with the
people
that have the biggest upside they can
build a team with right
if it is somebody that has a high score
of somebody can be in business but i
hope this makes sense to you and helps
you out
it's not one of those videos that i
think is going to get a lot of views i
just think the right person watching
this
is going to say this is exactly what i
had to watch because i've been
struggling with the decision of somebody
in business with
hopefully this gave you clarity if you
want to get this thing in a pdf
text the word trust to three one zero
three four zero one one three two
once again text the word trust to three
one zero
three four uh three four zero one one
three two we will send a pdf tune if
you're out of the uh the
us go to the link in the description
click on a link
subscribe to our newsletter and you will
get the pdf sent to you
and if you enjoyed this video the other
video i want you to watch is 15
qualities i look for
in becoming a potential inner circle
team member if you've never seen that
these two go
together click over here to watch that
video take care everybody bye-bye